You can create more interesting
movement by animating multiple objects,
or even the children of an item
as the parent itself moves.
In this example, the cards move
onto screen at different speeds,
helping to convey that
they are separate items.
When doing this, it's key that you do so
in a coordinated matter, here
we are achieving coordinated motion by
using a consistent direction and timing.
All cards move in from the bottom of
the screen, from different distances,
which causes the closing up effect.
Because they use the same duration and
interpolator, the acceleration and
deceleration will link
them perceptively,
thanks to the gestalt laws of
grouping that we looked at earlier.
When moving multiple
items at the same time,
be mindful to choreograph their
paths in a cohesive direction.
In this exaggerated example, each card
arrives from a different direction,
appearing chaotic.
Try sketching out the paths that items
will travel upon to check that they
are coordinated, avoiding overlapping
paths in conflicting directions.
In the real world,
few items move in a linear fashion, so
using linear motion can feel robotic and
unnatural.
In this example clicking on an item
performs a shared element transition
on the circle.
Notice that the difference between
this straight line transition and
curved transition.
The latter feels more natural.
Be judicious with this technique
as it can attract attention, so
make sure it's used when
that is your intention.
As we've seen, material surfaces
can transform their size,
shape, and position.
We've also seen how an items elevation
shows hierarchy and importance.
When animating a change
in size of an item,
you want to avoid having
your users mistake this for
a zoom effect, which might imply
an elevation change, like this example.
A good way to do this,
is to animate the width, and
the height at different rates,
making it clear what is changing.
Check the instructor's notes for
the source of these examples
to see how they are achieved.